I'm very happy to be interviewing a
friend and colleague Sean Miller who is
a PhD candidate at Marquette University
just blocks from here we're in the
Central Library right now
and as Sean as close to defending his
his research he's been doing a lot of
really interesting and innovative work
primarily in the philosophy of sex and
love but he's got some some other things
as well so I wanted to get him here in
part to talk about his dissertation
research but also to sound him out on a
number of other topics so welcome Sean
thank you why don't you talk first about
how you got into this this this area of
study was it just you know sex is sexy
you know it's a lot of criss cross paths
and reasons that caught me there I think
one reason one big reason was when I was
an undergrad at Utah State I took a
philosophy class just to cover a general
credit and I loved it so much that he's
decided to istic so you weren't a major
to start with I was originally a physics
major okay and then I eventually did a
dual major between physics and
philosophy at Utah State but as I was
accumulating more philosophy classes I
read this book called the story of
philosophy by will Donald yeah and it
was a really good a really captivated me
and there was a chapter on Schopenhauer
okay and I don't know if maybe was just
my mood at the time or maybe something
happen in my life but that really
captivated me now Schopenhauer had some
terrible things to say about women
he does yeah it does I think it from
that understand love and desire and all
sorts of topics well throughout the
whole terrible woman
no one no other philosopher talked about
love or sex it was just about
metaphysics of the politics or the
ethics Schopenhauer was the first person
actually talked about a philosophy
behind sex in love and that just really
fascinated me I didn't know that you
could philosophize about that so I
looked more into that and then the next
semester
I took a class on existentialism and we
read John Paul starts being nothingness
and there he had the section on
philosophy of the aspects and I thought
well yes and this was just mind-blowing
to me that people could actually thought
think about this these were topics and
so I decided so I looked it up in the
library at Utah State and there was just
this huge section on the phosphorus in
611 that that really grabbed my
attention and for my junior and senior
year I thought I'm just gonna work on
this stuff and I read all as much they
could yeah nothing just for fun and as
soon as I delve into those ideas I got
more immersed in so you came to
Marquette already having sort of a clear
focus for what you wanted to research
sort of yeah when I came to Marquette I
talked to a lot of professors about you
know I don't this topic and a lot of
them said you probably shouldn't it's
not a lot of research behind that but
you can use that as an avenue but pick a
broader thing yeah and at that time I
was I was really interested in
continental philosophy yeah so I thought
okay more if I specialize in
phenomenology and then just use sex and
love as a as a medium to talk about
phenomenology yeah
but over time I just lost interest in
phenomenology for its own sake right
yeah and but my my interest in love and
sex increase my thought Momsen go for
that as another man in itself you know I
will talk more about your dissertation
in moment but just a little bit of a
digression it strikes me that it's one
of those topics that bridges over a lot
of different approaches in philosophy
because you did a continental theorists
thinking pretty heavily about it right
and then there's there's analytic
philosophy you know they have some
interesting analyses of what constitutes
love and
even people like hairy frog for you know
have a book where he's delving into that
and then you know you'd start going back
into the history of philosophy all the
way back to like Plato's symposium right
so you get good history of philosophy
stuff and then you know there's there's
some discussion of in classical American
philosophy and the other thing is that
of course you can veer off into
literature disciplinary work definitely
yeah so does it allow you to does it
give you an end to be able to talk to
people coming from a lot of different
backgrounds oh it doesn't starting to
yeah when I first got into it I was just
mainly looking at it from a
philosophical angle mm-hmm but as I've
delved more into it I've tried to
incorporate things from psychology seems
from literature and sociological avenues
that really made my ideas
interdisciplinary and it also made it
more complex and I had a yeah how to
make it that's the best challenge I'm
just yeah I don't even one categorize
but it just became more complex over
time so your dissertation really moves
into two other areas that you didn't
mention one of which is education and
and the other of which I think going by
what kind of described its policy yeah
you know political science and Policy
Studies why don't you tell us about your
your dissertation yeah so my my research
in the dissertation is focusing on the
moral assumptions of psychologically sex
education classes in the United States
and curricula - right and the proof you
yeah I've looked at countless syllabi in
a lot of public school sex education
classes and I've determined that there
are more or less three different types
of moral theories that's incorporated
into sex education classes and after
investigating them I can categorize them
these are my categorizations
some sort of paternalistic sex education
or that consequentialist type or a
consent item so I've looked into these
different types and seen because a lot
of sex ed classes they don't to tell you
here's the ethical theory that we're
proposing yeah look into the curriculum
and try to garner out what sort of
ethical theory are they defaulting more
assuming in those you're sure doing
philosophical detective work right and
you might be uncovering assumptions that
the curriculum people themselves either
going to acknowledge or are unaware of
right okay yeah and by using a
philosophical analysis I've um arguing
that certain types of sex education
curricula on their moral assumptions are
flawed and if their whole entire
curriculum is based on that moral theory
yeah then that whole entire curriculum
just falls apart and so I try to look
forward into a curriculum that has a
good robust ethical theory as a
foundation and support and then you can
build a curriculum on that moral theory
so let's talk about the first one
paternalistic approaches that would
include the abstinence only
that's the spectrum yeah this is it does
it include anything else in there it's
mostly abstinence only you could you
could see it as something much more
strict as don't even talk about sex
period oh yeah so in a way if the
default is not to have sex education
that that falls into that paternalist I
think yeah so we would capture all those
sorts of okay are there are there public
high schools that are not doing any sex
education that you came across there are
there are a few yeah some states don't
even mandate it or require it okay and
so they're if they don't have to teach
it
yeah then might as well just not even
miles just skip it or if they do bring
it up it's usually in like in a health
class yeah but it's not it's not focused
is it also they also do it in the
biology classes I remember you know when
I was going back a long ways and I was
in a Catholic school but we did we did
have sex ed stuff crammed both into the
health and biology class yes I remember
actually watching a film that got a lot
of you know the kids kind of grossed
sure yeah but our teacher was it was a
farmer you know except she was very to
discuss it well I that's interesting
because I remember when I did sex that I
had a once in middle school and once in
high school and one in high school was
just in health class and yeah it was
mainly what you should avoid and not so
much in terms of this is what it is yeah
but I yeah I could see incorporating to
a biology class but I just you know when
I was you I was in high school at the
time my first paying job where I had you
know to do it w2 and all that stuff was
actually for the county of Waukesha who
had subcontracted to the YWCA to do this
program and it was essentially
abstinence only although we could
mention contraceptives and things like
that other kids they asked us about it
okay and it wasn't oriented along
consequentialist lines we we were called
teen peer educators so he in high school
you know team peer educators that go
into middle schools and I think we did a
few high schools and the idea was adults
can't get this message across to kids
because walks records have like a
terrible teen pregnancy crisis of the
heads and we would go in and we would we
would essentially scare the kids and we
would do these value clarifications
exercises where we wanted them to think
about you know what they wanted their
career to look like and stuff like that
and then we'd say and what about if you
had a unwanted pregnancy
or if you know what do you want your
ideal mate to look like now imagine you
get an STD yeah there was one other
thing oh and the other thing we did was
we would have them construct the guys
would do this with the guys and the
girls with the girls you know what is
your ideal mate looks like look like and
now Amanda she's in a terrible car
accident and you know her her beautiful
face is marred and and you're probably
not gonna be having sex with there
because your body's all mangled are you
still going to be you know attached her
and if so basis trying to shame them
basically into saying that and you know
these programs were totally ineffective
yeah a penis for yeah I loved it because
they paid us for all the training and
they pay us to go in and you get to get
out of school to do it and so that be a
paternalistic wonder would that be a
consequentialist was going to the other
that would definitely be paternalistic
one the way I look at consequentialist
is avoiding negative consequences such
as unwanted pregnancies and STI say they
would be a bit more comprehensive and
explaining contraceptives okay yeah
that's the whole entire for this is that
so there's so the the paternalistic ones
tend to be oriented towards producing
the actions of gruesome just to stay
away from all this until you're married
right and then the consequentialist ones
it's to get them to see that there's
these consequences if you take this
option there's these consequences if you
do this we want you to do this instead
make sure you use copies right okay yeah
so they take the precautions because
it's a risky activity and here's the way
to mitigate the risks okay that's
basically yeah so I mean are those
effective it's a bit more effective than
well actually a lot more effective than
the paternalistic sex education yeah and
I think that's a good start that's a
good way to get the sex education going
but I still find it's lacking
features because when it comes to sex
education should be a sexuality
education so Chan to talk about gender
healthy relationships and try to break
the mold of certain social norms of
sexuality and these expectations and the
comprehensive or the consequentialist
sex education doesn't really do it it
just focuses on what you should avoid
yeah and so it presumes that somebody's
already got the right values and play
right then they'll make the right
decision yeah which is kind of a big
assumption with fourteen-year-old kid is
yeah yeah the values in place are the
right ones and there's no need to
question them it's the default position
okay what's the what's the third one the
third one is a consent based sex ed and
this is fairly new right now on the
California mandates it for high school
interests and consent is optional to
teach in other states but it is mandated
in California and that is coming from
the ontological angle so yeah I teach
sexual autonomy sexual consent and there
it's a lot better because if it's coming
from sexual autonomy then it's up to the
students to kind of think about their
own values and incorporate those values
into the life and then move forward and
trying to be more autonomous so that's
their own values how much of it is
played how much emphasis is placed on
understanding the values of a partner
and you know reaching some sort of I
don't wanna say compromise because
consent isn't going to be a compromise
if it is then it's already at that
corpse right right but but reaching some
sort of point where both partners are
are not just okay with but but happy
about what's going on so this is where I
think there's some good elements but
there's so something missing in a
consent based because too much emphasis
on the the the sort of you know the the
fact the the person who's supposed to
respect consent
what you know constitutes consent or a
little bit yeah when it comes to consent
the whole idea is to treat the other
persons and as if they're your own
that's a guy that's very contine angel
yeah yeah and there's supposed to be
some sort of mutual dynamic to happen
instead of just one a single person than
amicus so that's that's important that's
that's really good but what's missing is
the the assumptive values that's in
place about certain gender inequalities
for example are still at the problem
amount of group of power dynamics yeah
and one example that I give is every to
receive consent means that you have to
receive a yes and the way that our
societal structures are set up all men
need to do is manipulate women to get
that yes yeah so we often here yes means
yes which is great but what comes after
the s and that's something that's
normally discussed in consent based sex
ed is it because they just don't have
the time to discussion or is it there's
this essentially that that's where the
curriculum leaves off I think partially
it's because it's just so new oh the
curriculum is just starting with yes
means yes okay affirmative consent and
that's the foundation of the basis and
we don't have a lot of research because
it's so new in terms of well how does
this work what more can be added to it
and what more could we do to inform the
students about what happens after the
yes yeah and if the yes is all that's
needed that's the foundation great but I
think we can do much better and try to
figure out well what what can we do more
than just giving a receiving consent
with developing sexual autonomy to yeah
it's if the whole idea is trying to help
the students develop their own values
but if the structures are still in place
then the presumptive values are the
default values of assist
and so doesn't really question into
social norms or the values of that
society
yes it seems like there's two related
problems there's there's that broad
problem and then there's the fact that
we're talking about you know adolescents
and adults in we could say in
development so that part of I mean if
you think about what what I have to
think for my memory to do this and you
probably do sorry I'm not quite as far
but think about what it was like being
an adolescent and having your first you
know sexual experiences and trying to
make sense of them we didn't have a very
great resources to to work with and but
you know then over time figuring out
what you what you like what you enjoy
what you don't like what you know what
perhaps you you saw is okay at first and
now see as demeaning or more vice versa
how do you take you know how do you
build that into a curriculum then you
know how do you know how do you sort of
it's almost like you know in trying to
hit a moving target you've got to
actually to chart the course that they
they were going do you need some sort of
developmental account to do that it's
it's really difficult in terms of how to
properly teach the students what they
want when it's it's gonna be diverse and
varied amongst the students yeah a lot
of students have requested that they
kind of want to know how it's done they
want a how-to guide
well that's very that's very clear yeah
they do and say if they don't get it
from from sex ed they're gonna get it
from they did was what we did as kids
yeah but the porn was you know more
likely some you know uncles - totally
you know crazy expectations sure yeah
yeah and it's really difficult to figure
out well how do you give them a how-to
guide when the sexuality is much broader
than that yeah but at the same time
students likes and dislikes is going to
marry and the best that teachers can
give is just
here's the here's the broad range here's
the I'm gonna wanna say theoretical
aspects but here's the ways that people
have done it here's the combinatorics
you might say alright what's that the
combinatorics all the different possible
oh you know combinations sort of like
going on a Wikipedia oh yeah people
click around
yeah yeah but so I mean I think one of
the worries that a lot of teachers have
parents is that if you're doing that
here you're essentially endorsing you
should do all these things oh yeah well
I think I don't think that's a really
good argument because just teaching
people a certain thing to do it yeah I'm
gonna say when we teach Nietzsche
exactly exactly yeah I don't have to be
the uber man you don't have to but I
think learning about this information is
essential and it'll be useful if you
decide to venture into it or not and
it's a good tool to have yeah but at the
same time it's also a good tool because
then you understand people's
proclivities and there's no sense of
shaming others as they don't match yours
or if there's no sense of trying to
fulfill the people's I expect
expectations or even your own
expectations because you might have
wrong expectations and if people don't
fulfill them then we're not questioning
those social norms of sort of
expectations we should hold so you're
are you still in process of reading are
you now at the point where you've got to
work more or less consolidated and
you're getting ready to defend the work
is basically done I've give I've given
drafts to my committee members and just
waiting for them to give me say yeah I'm
about to feed back on a few much
chapters which is great and I've just
try to update the chapters or try to see
how they
the first couple chapters were a lot of
work but I'm hoping yeah as the chapters
would be much easier I mean it seems
like the sort of project that unlike the
case with many philosophy dissertations
a lot of people outside philosophy are
going to want to to see if the DA plans
to publish it
I would like to either mine it out and
so I can publish articles from it and
into journal articles or make it more
robust and to get a lot of feedback from
others and hopefully publish it to a
book if I can yeah either a scholarly
book or well it could be it could turn
into both you could have I would like
that dynamic version and then sort of
for you know high school teachers policy
makers a PTA I would love that yeah yeah
and if I get enough ideas especially
with my positive it you know maybe you
even form a curriculum that would help
produce much better education that's
interesting so that one of the things I
wrote down that I wanted to ask you
about is you know where you see your
career trajectory going right now you
know the job market in academics in
general is terrible it's particularly
bad in philosophy and you seem to be
somebody who's not only interested in
but but good at working outside of the
walls of the Academy try to I mean is
that where you see your career headed
and doing like say coaching or
curriculum development or workshops that
sort of thing I'm not sure yet as of
right now my my trajectory is to
continue in the track position to be a
professor somewhere yeah but if there is
another avenue that I find more passion
then I will head down to that would you
work outside of philosophy if you had
you know the possibility say of working
in a Gender Studies department or I
don't know what sort of department's
focus specifically on sex and law
but if those were open how'd you apply
for those if they're throw open and I
could do do work in that field yeah I
could definitely work in that yeah for
sure
yeah I think that's something that would
be helpful to me and kind of brought out
my ideas and yeah incorporating new
information and also if I can still do
philosophical thinking then I'm
completely happy with that yeah yeah
well you can certainly do philosophical
thinking outside of eyes yeah definitely
Wow I was a matter of fact being in the
Academy sometimes you know unduly
constricts what you can focus yeah
definitely so there were a few other
things I wanted to ask you got as well
I should mention so Sean has a blog
called Sean Miller's ideas and he has
many many ideas if you scroll through it
and then the synopsis is sex love desire
conceptions of gender those sorts of
things but there's there's a lot of
really interesting material in there and
you keep it up too which is I try to you
know it takes quite a lot yeah should
mention to Sean he has an Instagram
account of coffee and research so you
should check that out as well so one of
the things I saw that you did recently
is you did a podcast episode about
sexual resilience yeah right and and so
that got me thinking in terms of you
know you've talked about this
paternalistic model a consequentialist
we might say utilitarian model a dant
illogical model and now when you start
talking about resiliency we start
getting into things that start to you
know seem more like virtue of the traits
of character so what is sexual
resiliency it's not like what some
people might imagine sexual endurance
being able to have sex all night long is
right so I think resiliency they can go
to do two different routes one type is
the thinking of two people one person
acquiescence to any sort of sexual
to whatever his or her partner says and
just passively accepts what's happening
the other type is more active in his or
her needs and desires and will actively
say yes or no and if that person says
yes and then trying to pinpoint exactly
well this is how I want it the person
who is active I think has resiliency
because they're more autonomous and
there are likes and dislikes they can
engage with their partner much more
forcefully and try to help them
determine a mutual relationship instead
of just passively letting the partner
having to make the decisions for them
right yeah yeah so that's one type is I
think be more active in one sexuality is
is such a resiliency but the other type
is and I've seen this amongst amongst
peers and people that I've read is that
after some sort of sexual mishap or
sexual trauma there's people who are
just kind of stopped mentally stuck and
they just can't really get out of it and
that's totally understandable
yes they told me if I'm wrong about this
typology but one possibilities they shut
down shirt entirely I'm not going to do
any of this another possibility is they
simply repeat you know whatever it is
that they're doing and then they you
know wonder 10 partners later how come
everybody is a jerk yeah and then the
other is to sort of go off the deep end
and just try to lose themselves in some
something maybe more transgressive
riskier yeah yeah uncover is sort of the
gamma that does sponsor yeah that
they've they've been they've had some
sort of sexual trauma or social mishap
and that is really unfortunate and they
don't have the tools or the skills in
order to help themselves
yeah and I've seen people who underwent
a similar sort of thing but they've
gotten the the grit or the resilience to
kind of bounced back to process it yeah
okay and to kind of move forward but at
least not let the trauma kind of take
over yeah so they don't do the same
thing the next time it's not the
proverbial get back on the horse
right you know it should you know right
or it's a terrible breakup you know your
friends well go find somebody else yeah
and yeah when with doesn't mean to get
back to where you were because I think
after yeah like that it's you now
changes your character but it means to
move forward in a way that you can
instead of getting back into this cycle
yeah so I think resilience is a way to
help you to get out of second to move
forward so what what builds that I don't
know that's something I'm thinking about
and thinking and thinking that a way to
incorporate into my positive account
because my positive account is a virtue
ethical angle and I think resilience is
partially how to activate your autonomy
more forcefully so that's something that
yeah education at the very beginning of
of children could be helpful and I'm
trying to give up some other skills of
how to build resiliency you know when we
talk about virtues we think of them as
character traits that that transfer
across domains so a person who is just
will not just be just in terms of say
their personal relationships will also
be just in a wider social political
scale and we could talk perhaps about
you know how the how the virtues you
know what what do they actually look
like in in the domain of personal
relationships and sexuality
so with resiliency that's something
that's that's being discussed and looked
at in other fields in terms particularly
of like work or you know we're having
students being told quite a bit that
they need to be more resilient
some of that's a little misguided I
think but some of it seems to be you
know quite good so can those inform
sexual resiliency or is sexual
resiliency something more
domain-specific do you think I've talked
to some people about that and some
people think that resiliency can be
broad and it just captures such
resiliency so if you teach resiliency in
a broad way then they have that general
tool you know and then that could be
applied to such a resiliency but I've
also talked to other people who think
that such resiliency is its own thing
and even if you teach general resiliency
it doesn't fully capture sexual
resiliency and maybe sexual jealousy is
something that is just a completely
different category or maybe we need
another curly fry term yeah so I know I
it's something that I think still needs
to be researched to capture that what
are the other virtues that you think are
particularly important in this this
domain of sex love relationships desire
mm-hmm I think definitely the emotional
stuff so compassion and empathy are
really important mutual respect instead
of making the full decisions yeah there
has to be in people looking at Weaver I
says I don't ask to be courage well
either that's what I want to hear about
because that's that's one of the
traditional virtues it is and you know
well somebody like Alistair McIntyre
says you can't develop many of the other
virtues without having justice courage
and honesty those are the ones that he
identifies as an architectonic
interesting man you know you see like in
the accounts of the Stoics and yeah I
miss Aquinas there's this emphasis on
courage isn't just like you know running
into the burning building it's any time
that you have to like you know you're
gonna push against resistance yeah to do
what what needs to be done so I could
see how that would fit okay good so to
make the case for the viewers because
they may not
right you know well I think courage is
helpful because it helps people to say
no it also helps people to say yes and
what to do after that yes and courage is
a way to not not be passive and
acquiesce yeah is to be totally active
in your decisions and in your whole
well-being instead of just being fully
passive not just in the sexual act but
also passive in the social more is at
the time just accepting the oh yeah I
think sense and if you challenge those
values I think you need courage to in
order to do that you ask me you're
facing others what about you know
there's an old-fashioned word temperance
right now we would more like innocent
moderation or self-control I think a lot
of people you know I think there's two
sort of two mindsets about this one is
well that definitely we know that
definitely bears on sexual matters
because Plato says so the story on his
face so Aristotle says everybody says so
but then the question is well how much
is is the right amount and what mindset
and I think there's other people who
sort of view it as because of that sort
of oppressive well if you're talking
about temperance and sexuality you know
pushing these norms on people and sex is
supposed to be just fun right right and
so is there is a room for something like
a virtue of temperance and if so I mean
it's probably not going to look that
much like I mean I think for example
about the Stoics and they're the
ancients dogs have very clear gender
roles established you know as a matter
of fact epictetus leo basically almost
kicks a guy out of his his classroom
saying you know you look like a girl you
know yeah and you know he gives a lot of
black shirt after that and we probably
want to say well that's socially you
know conditioned norms at the time and
if Epictetus was around today maybe he
he he'd be more comfortable with gender
fluidity or so anything like that is is
Temperance to let me put it this way is
Temperance too old-fashioned of
you have a place and what you're talking
about I think temperance can still have
a place but in a very broad way okay I
don't have the I have a foundation but I
haven't worked out the the specifics
I think self-control or temperance can
be done if you find out some sort of
aspect of things of your second thought
is consuming your character okay and if
it's not then that's that's my position
in a nutshell but I do want to work more
on those specifics yeah
what about what other virtues would be
the mentioned compassion or empathy
we've talked about justice to some
degree resiliency courage possibly
temperance understood what other of the
traditional virtues would we want to
incorporate well related to courage I
think honesty and you mentioned I think
it's going to be a big one and not just
being truthful but being truthful in a
in a caring way I guess is about you
haven't especially yeah that's one side
of it you can say things that are
truthful the very cutting and yeah
that's it yeah yeah yeah and especially
in the second a moment where people are
typically very vulnerable and so being
brutally honest can be quite harsh
you're not very good at what you're
doing right right exactly yeah so I
think being honest in a nice way in a
careful way and where you're and I'm in
caring way I think is a way to do it and
the way to tie all these virtues up and
I don't know how to teach this is you
have to have some sort of sexual firm
esis yeah that's what I was gonna ask
you about sexual wisdom yeah is there
such a thing
I think there I think there is I think
there is because when we can think about
consent yeah a lot of consent is
nonverbal and yeah that's a really good
point for an ASIS helps us yeah you
to really be good at reading body
language to be really good at looking at
facial expressions if they're really
good at the entire dynamic to make sure
that it's okay to keep going or not
and if you don't have that sexual wisdom
then you could be making a mistake you
can miss read things or you could cause
something that's that's gonna be
inappropriate and so I think sexual
wisdom is definitely needed yeah but I
mean coming from Aristotle do a way to
gain for nieces is through experience
and so it's really hard to yes yeah
that's one of the interesting things I
mean Lacan points this out in his
lectures because he's always interested
in sexuality was good Freudian right but
he also one of one of my favorite works
of his is his seminar that he did on the
ethics of psychoanalysis and he points
out that human sexuality is just a mess
because you know we have all these ideas
coming to us and they don't even make
full full sense together if we if we
analyze them from our culture some of
them you know age-old some of them you
know very contemporary say in the
advertising and so we've got that little
mess to deal with and then we've got
these urges that were feeling nothing
back to like being sixteen you know how
strong those were and how in some
respects scary they are and in other
respects exhilarating and then you're
dealing with other people who are going
through the same thing and they have no
idea what the hell is going on you're
right even though a little bit and we
all try to pretend like we're in control
and and we know what's what because we
don't want to be revealed as not being
in the know right and so you put that
together it's almost like a recipe for
for everybody to be getting the wrong
messages and making the wrong choices
it's it's a miracle that any of us wind
up well-adjusted at all and then we have
you know psychotherapy or we have you
know other you know spiritual counseling
or virtue ethics coaching to help us
kind of not not get to a perfect place
but at least be not so screwed up as we
apparently our yeah so that's for adults
you know he was you know he's not doing
that with kids and then you think well
how would you do that in terms of
managing all these kids in the high
school it's tough yeah I think there's a
lot of different methods case studies oh
yeah yeah I've thought of a few case
studies that sometimes I teach in my
ethics class now you use them as well
and I teach out that the students really
respond they do yeah do you follow up so
what I'll do is I actually have them as
assignments then they first have to
complete you know apply a couple moral
theory you say who the stakeholders are
and then half the class will get them
wrong in one way or the other and then
we actually talked about them and have
the students who like you know got the
better answers say well here's why I
sighs do this and this and this here's
you know here's what got left out do you
do something like that where it's kind
of an iterative process or do you some
of the activity I do yeah here's some
scenarios and is this considered
consensual or not and then we go I have
the customer through the exercises yeah
and I noticed I try to make it so that
it's that each group has hopefully 50%
50% female and we go through the
exercises and then when I go through
this article yeah classic article about
contine consent and then we go back the
cases Oh interesting and then see if
they change of mind and and then I asked
them when you guys were discussing hoops
did the males have an opinion the
females have a different opinion does
that tell you something about how yeah
the standard things about consent or not
so what what if your experience is bad
in terms of Holly approaching after
reading the article after they read the
article they're more thoughtful of what
consent could be
cuz we don't hear about consent in sex
education classes yeah so the default is
well that person didn't say no so if
there's no know that it's on a good
consent but then after reading this
article they realize it's a bit more
complex in Newark's in that and they
realize okay so basically it seems like
there's some troublesome aspects with it
yeah so do you think we need something
like you know an iterative process like
that within sex education rather than
what we gotta go through this module and
then go to this module we need something
more comprehensive something where the
same stuff is being you know yeah exam
and I think there's gonna be multiple
methods of how to do it so case studies
where you just come lured out there and
let them discuss in case there's an
iterative process I think is also very
helpful class activities exercises could
be helpful and there's some curricula
tries to engage students in doing that
yeah and it's really nice when they can
have students engage in that sort of way
yeah yeah so I've got a bunch of other
things we have to ask you about one of
them is I'm actually going to jump down
quite a bit
you you've been going to conferences
that are focused in particular on
sexuality in one way or another yeah I
imagine some of some of our viewers when
they hear about that I mean you've
actually met dr. Ruth I have okay and
she you know she's I remember listening
to her in the 1980s she was old but
she's very sort of she manages to make
things it's still about sex but but it's
not clinical but it's it's dealing with
things and let's call it a more sedate
manner is that what these conferences
are
in general and as it's sort of serious
discussion of these matters and who goes
to them it is not in a as serious as
father conferences because there's a
there's a structure and there's a rigor
in that I've noticed I have lots of
conferences people are have this very
serious tone and hosts and so I was kind
of expecting that when I went to these
sexuality conferences and they they're
just much more lighthearted and they're
free-flowing and gay and that threw me
off for a bit I was like okay this is
how it works and I just have much more
relaxed yeah yeah most of the people who
are sex educators some therapists or
social workers okay or people who deal
with sexuality in their work and so I
went to it's more practitioner than
theorists right it's yeah I think in
both of these conferences I was the only
philosopher there okay
why do you feel out of place because of
being the only philosopher at first I
did but they're very welcoming and to
this day I still keep in touch with with
a lot of them and it's very nice that we
can so think about the issues together
and collaborate together and but I I
would to a couple them last year and
most of them are workshop stuff like
this is how this is a method I'm
thinking about how to teach sex
education better or a different angle on
sex therapy or sexuality that they can
teach the the rest of the informants and
then they can take that to them either
clinical practices or inform the rest of
their their workforce hey there's
something I learned about we should
probably incorporate this into our
classes or
therapy sessions as well yeah so it's
nice they can do that yeah okay
so are you gonna continue going to these
conferences you think that's sort of a
major mani are you gonna be presenting
this research those eventually yeah I
want to go to open them a few more times
just to have experience of how that
works and how it functions and make it
because it's not of the FASTA conference
at all so I have to take out the
philosophic right and present it as yeah
but I went to a conference in June and
it's a major conference and it's in
Denver and it's a two or three days long
and so I'll be going there and then
after that I'm hoping there's another
conference either it's up to her or in
August okay yeah that's that's the sort
of thing perhaps given you know the
recent issues that are reported in
Milwaukee that maybe we need to have
something here and by that I mean you
know outbreak of STDs teenagers high
school students I mean to swing back to
the models of Education so the
paternalistic stuff doesn't work at all
right it is an actually
counterproductive where it tends to lead
to higher rates of teen pregnancy STDs
because it's it's you know dangling with
stuff out in front of them but just
telling them don't do that and that's
interstate resources I've seen I've seen
some studies where some students think
that because that usually personal sick
sex that doesn't teach them about
contraception yeah
and so they don't know how to use it and
so when they are I guess tempted or have
sex they about writings about
contraception
with them and that's yeah that's gonna
be of their own but in terms of whether
it increases increases problems there
are some people that I've read in in
interviews where they said well I
thought since I had psyched I'm ready
I'm already used to good sometimes we'll
just keep having sex
oh and so that also crazy idea and so
with that that's true that sort of
old-fashioned emphasis on virginity yeah
you know it's interesting one of the
people I do a lot of work out is
Wollstonecraft maritime yes don't craft
it's just had a whole discussion in
there because it needed to be had at the
time in her vindication of the rights of
women about virtues and whether chastity
is really yeah and she's she's making
the case she's essentially you know
gender equality feminists saying that
you know listen men and women need to be
on the same playing field and so the
notion of there being virtues that are
that are specific only to one one gender
she's you know rejected was totally
going against most of the time including
in one way that women and she's gonna
you know very great discussion in there
about about chastity and how it's been
and this is you know over two hundred
years ago
that is if you don't have the critical
apparatus for that but it's not getting
to to a lot of these educators and
thereby not to the kids yeah I've seen a
lot of different accounts from different
curricula different states or they try
to teach what it means to be used goods
really in that curriculum its are they
steam a sizing it in terms of like this
is what you ought to avoid or are they
trying to sort of demystify this this
you know virginity no oh no because one
could be quite positive and the other
was clearly just reinforcing yeah the
most of a lot of it
reinforcing and they used examples like
there's a piece of tape and every time
actually someone as if you were sticking
the tape on someone and then notice at
the end here the tape not sticky anymore
I've seen food examples as well and it's
just not helpful I don't know since it's
a way to get students to feel more
shameful if they have sex they feel like
oh no it's sticky tape I'm just this
used of food and I did read an account
from Elizabeth Smart she was one who was
kidnapped in Utah oh yeah I think 10 12
years ago and she said one of the main
reasons that she didn't escape from
captor is because her captor raped her
oh good well we're seeing that with like
sex trafficking and these these grooming
rings where they targeted very you know
vulnerable kids and you know start
getting them to have sex oftentimes
giving them giving them drugs and then
that's the consistent message you better
stay with us because nobody's gonna want
you nobody's gonna take you back alright
it's really great quite sad I mean with
a big problem here in Milwaukee we're a
hub for for sex trafficking even still
[Music]
high-profile cases
what's talking about something a bit
more so with in in relation to sexuality
one of the things that I brought up
earlier is we've got a lot of you know
ancient medieval early modern theory it
tends to have a lot of cultural
assumptions built into it you think
about Plato's symposium for example
right and sometimes these are cultural
assumptions that are they're not even
similar to sort of what we might call
conservative ones in our own time
because in the symposium obvious it's
male-male relationship so that's that's
where the real action is and you know
male-female that's okay but who would
ever fall in love with this is his wife
you know it's really about that third
thing so it is the stuff that we have
that we might teach if we're doing a
sort of historical survey of Sachs law
of desire is that still useful for us
today and if so it's not where do we
need to just say well that was you know
old stuff you know you know maybe take
stuff from the 20th century on and make
that part of our not the curriculum for
kids but the curriculum let's say we
were going to educate the educators
should they be reading the symposium
should they be reading you know medieval
you know monastic texts about because
they're very interesting stuff about the
nature of marriage a faction and
conjugal love or where should we to say
well that that's not helpful anymore
there's too many you know assumptions
built into it we need to have all new
stuff I think ideally it would be nice
if they could because by learning the
history yeah they gain the tools and the
skills of okay so this is historical
context of why those they have those
ideas in the first place Yeah right yeah
and then later on you have another
person who kind of a response back and
so you can kind of see the whole
dialogue of the interchange and
you get a more robust idea of how
sexuality evolved and our desires
involved in and how notions of love have
changed over time and so when you teach
the students or as an adult you have a
broader picture of what sexuality is and
it helps I think question your own
social mores because you begin to think
okay so I'm just part of this historical
progression instead of this is a natural
thing we got it right this time
yeah and I think it's very helpful if
they have that but when it comes to sex
education I mean there is a standard
curriculum for four seconds you need to
be certified and I I have to
double-check the classes I don't know if
there's like a history of thought behind
it maybe there is but it would be nice
if they could implement that yeah does
that nationwide for that certification
or is that state-by-state
it's nationwide okay but the way to
achieve that certificate it is a complex
process oh yeah just because there is no
school there are a couple of schools
that teach you how to get it but it's
it's not as if you can go to any school
to get ya house and certification you
have to get from legit resources and I
mean for example that the conferences I
went to that's one way to get credits
nice for example yeah and are you
working for exact currently is that to
that part of currently I'm not because
if the first register for it and I that
cost money it doesn't see this
I've not registered for it yet but I
would like to certified yes yeah that
sounds like a great adjunct to having
the philosophy PhD yeah yeah what what
would that take how much how many
hours or classes things are involved
that is a pretty substantive like sort
of like the equivalent of doing say a
master's degree I think it's very
similar to a master's degree okay
I think it's I know there's a specific
number of credits or hours that you have
to achieve yeah and there are certain
classes that are essential and then the
rest are I guess electives yeah but yeah
it's been a while since I've actually
looked at the crew them I know that
there are hours and credits you have to
achieve yeah that's good
it is yeah it's very helpful that they
have that sort of thing one of the other
questions I wanted to ask you has to do
with how sex education connects up with
teaching outside of school and by
teaching I don't mean the Matic you know
you know education along the same lines
but what I mean is all these other
things that end up teaching kids so you
know the media their peers parents is
there a lot of prospect for sex
education in school to really do much
for kids given all the other things that
are giving them messages in one way or
the other the lifeline for some of these
kids you know I think I think a really
good sex education class would help
students take in the information
especially things like the media and
help some question help them determine
some what are they a student what sort
of gender norms or session or are they
assuming and then break it down and eyes
and question that and hopefully the
students we were like okay so this thing
that I'm taking it they might just think
as a normal thing or that it's the
natural or that's a simple thing but if
they start to question that then ya
think okay so this media thing isn't
accurate when it comes to certain norms
yeah everything we did almost have
certain genres right
antek movies for ice you know we learn
one set of things from those Jerry
Springer style shows you learn something
totally different documentaries yeah
yeah reality shows yeah yeah I think we
robust execution would definitely have
this questionable concern and to
question of social mores which i think
is my philosophy is important a little
bit education yeah completely agree and
that's why I think the work that you're
doing is you know not only innovative
but important it's important both for
both sides
you know philosophy I don't have to
saying something that you already agree
with philosophy has to you know do much
more than just be within its little spot
yeah yeah even even just do more in the
academy outside that would be very
helpful but then you know the when I
find it in my work a lot of the time is
the fields that are outside philosophy
but that can be informed by philosophy
they're not there they're often very
happy much much happier than other
academics are to have us come in and
give them something with a bit more
rigor and substance that they can chew
on because they're not getting that
within their their own feel there's a
camera hunger out there for more depth
and structure is that the case for for
sexuality in general would you say sex
education I think so yeah there's
definitely I mean a lot of students
crave and better sex education yeah and
at least in the United States the polls
show that a lot of parents want schools
to have a much better sex education oh
that's good it is something nice to hear
it is yeah and so there is this crave
for there's a lot for it yeah what about
when they get to college I mean you you
teach college students you're not that
far in age from them
as I am so I think they still probably
see you as kind of appears I deserve
them a little bit more closely than I do
they're coming from all different
backgrounds some of them may have had
really great sex education some of them
they had just miss them all yeah it's
all the way in between and because of
the way we structure the core curricula
they're probably not getting a class
focused on those sorts of issues and
they're at a time when they're being
encouraged to experiment as much as
possible you live it up because it's
College you know there's all these these
these social pressures what do you see
in your in your classes when you're
talking with students about this they do
you think they would want to have like a
three credit class like sir like sex ed
that you should have had in high school
but you didn't get to have or something
like that it's a little bit mixed I
think I think a lot of students deep
down would like to have a class about
sexuality in general yeah but it's
interesting a lot of colleges do offer
human sexuality but it's it's as a core
thing where it would satisfy a general
ed requirement or something
often that building over there and
they've got to like you don't know yeah
it's actually the catalog to find it
yeah it's usually not requirement this
class but I couldn't because conflicted
with another class actually there's two
prerequisites
it was intro to family Family Studies
and then it was like wow and you gotta
be a junior and this is when I was a
sophomore they really set up a lot of
obstacle asou they really do I think
just that for people who majored in yeah
studies I still want to do this so I
asked the professor
just sit in the class and he was fine
with that which was nice that I could
yeah yeah we don't have anything
remotely like that
I mean you figured it out on your own by
having relationships you're hooking up
yeah stuff like that and we would have
the odd discussion say in a whip class
about sex or mythology classes are good
for that because there's always myths
about sex nothing there's nothing
definitely not the philosophy the
philosophy of sex in love I would love
to teach that and I mean I know more cat
has a human sexuality class but I don't
think a lot of students know about that
either and it's in the psychology
department oh yeah yeah yeah I don't
know what their curriculum is I don't
know what it's set up but I do know that
sexuality class yeah I've used intro
classes sometimes because you've got
such a broad you know sort of umbrella
or which you continue and I've set them
up using themes and so I would sometimes
do that in terms of like philosophy of
sex love and desire or love friendship
and desire yeah but the problem I always
found was that the 15 week the 15 week
semester and the fact that you did have
to do an intro so they got to be getting
some ethics some metaphysics of the mr.
Balaji men that we couldn't do very much
yeah you know yeah I didn't I do the
classic theme a degree 2 and comes into
your classes and I let the students
choose the topics Oh at the beginning of
the semester yeah school and it never
fails they always choose philosophy
lower floors sauce or Boston friendship
they choose one of those three things
yeah and I do in a very robust way I I
calculate how many points they want in
terms of which which team they want and
they baseless points on okay so that
many points means that they want this
much more amount of class than if they
came to this theme
okay and so in terms of law success and
love it's it's in the medium range so I
spend about maybe two weeks on it yeah
and I tried to delve into some religion
topics and the law students are thankful
for it
but I wish I could tell them too much
more yeah and that's that's the case
with leymah though that we teach
we're so restricted you know I mean we
do have alternate like 8-week classes
and stuff like that that's even tougher
the right to figure out what you're
gonna pack in there we're so hamstrung
by the you know Carnegie credit hour so
I mean does that point to the need to do
this in alternate forms you know I'll
say not for credit classes or things
along those lines
I think there'd be lots of ways to do it
we could have classes that could be very
helpful I think just giving more more
time dedicated to saying hey there's
some classes that are dedicated to
either gender or sexuality and maybe
more students would be interested in
taking those sorts of classes yeah I try
to look at the next semester's classes
and if they're offering a feminism I
always tell my students a they're
offering feminism
yeah semester and you guys aren't just
doing that I think it'd be very helpful
if a lot of falsehood cards would offer
either philosophy of law or philosophy
of success even as an elective a lot of
universities who teach that it's going
to be very popular yes yeah yeah so I've
got two other questions yeah so one is
kind of off the wall and you know if
they answered if you know if it's too
embarrassing but you know you you're
doing all this work in sort of meta
education about sex love desire and
stuff like that
what do you wish that you had think
about teenage you what do you wish that
you had learned that they didn't teach
you in your teenage years
well okay so I'll start with this when I
was an undergrad I noticed that a lot of
my peers were critiquing the way that
women dressed okay
and there were I learned later on it was
gender policing them yeah and I didn't
have that turf war and that it bothered
me when my peers did that by it and have
the vocabulary I'd have them okay me for
doing that ology just thought was this
emotion and I couldn't figure out why I
was feeling this and I couldn't figure
out the way to explain what was wrong
with it yeah so I would like it in my
teenage years that they could express
some sort of gender norms and gender
expectations and knowing that those are
not considered naturally those are
things that are ultra those no cultural
yeah and that even if it has a
biological basis or has a biology of
information it is a lot of cultural
mm-hmm information behind it and that if
it's cultural based and cultures change
over time then those things could
definitely be questioned yeah and I
never got that until I was in college
yeah that's what that's a really good
point I think back to just how things
were for myself growing up you know in
the 70s and 80s and the like incredible
anxiety that so many of the guys
especially the athletes had about being
perceived in any way as being gay and
gay was like not just a sexual category
it was like a study category across the
board right and and you you had to be
very very careful but but of course if
you allowed yourself to be seen as
worrying about that that was a sign
you're gay
oh there's a double behind there there
is and I think about how much effort
especially above like the football team
and the wrestlers and people like that
went into and some of them probably
working you know just policing these
these these these boundaries and you
know fortunately for me I didn't get
bullied on that account but I saw other
kids who you know one thing or another
happened and somebody labelled them and
then they just get beaten up you know
and now thank god that's that's I mean
that is still the norm in some places
but you know I think my own kids
wouldn't want my kids to have to go
through all that crazy [ __ ] and why
was it that way well you know cultural
norms you know it was reinforced a lot
by you know parents and coaches and the
movies and things like that and I'm glad
things have changed yeah yeah the other
question that I've got for you outside
of the realm of philosophy in this area
of study who are the authors that you
find particularly good and you'd like to
recommend as sort of reading suggestions
for for other people oh why do you like
them - again the philosophy of sexuality
philosophy education or just oh well it
could be in in terms of sexuality and in
general you know what what are the
people that you keep going back to and
saying that's that's I want to read more
of his or her work in a ok but my the
big book that I first always recommend
it's emelina gauss keys come as you are
and she is she's just really good at her
writing style I truck I would like to
imitate her writing style but it's not
it's not it's been for
general audience yeah and when I first
read it I threw up a bit because I'm so
used to academic yeah but after a while
I really got into it and the book is
just about how the science of sexuality
has been around since Aristotle
yeah hasn't been contempt modernly
looked at until lately but the science
of female sexuality hasn't been around
since maybe until 1990 yeah and so the
whole book is looking at the section of
the science of female sexuality and
trying to explain what all that is to to
a general audience and it's really good
and it's very very powerful it's not
just about sexual eye but it's just it's
also about emotions it's about stress
and it's also about how to how to think
about oneself as a sexual being and with
all the cultural norms that's being a
founded upon us so I was going one book
I would definitely recommend is Lena
Gauss keys coming to our another book
that I I go to when it comes to
philosophy of sex and love is it's like
that the classic book but it's Alan
Sobel's philosophy of sex and love oh
yeah it's nothing that the big volume am
I mistaken there was somebody else's
somebody did like a four-volume
oh yeah he did make a an encyclopedia
was in the editor of this yeah listen
suck vixx from yeah it was it was a big
thing that he did that time so that's
also very helpful as well yeah while you
set the one I'm thinking about is it's
it's just it was published by Palgrave
and it's a second edition and he just
looks at these different issues in a
very in a very analytical way okay and
he looks at love and has a whole process
about well what does love that
meditation love what is sex and you
thanks the medics of that and then looks
at gender as well and that really got my
thought process going about the
philosophical issues certainly that I
thought that was very cool that you
could think about that in this rigorous
yeah yeah so those would be the two
books that I would probably start off
with okay thinking about the philosophy
of sex and love is there anything else
you'd like to bring up or we haven't
covered I think we for whatever thing I
mean I you find sex education really
important and I think philosophical
tools if a minute that is really helpful
and I'm hoping to keep going in why sex
education should be more comprehensive
than more robust well I'm really looking
forward to seeing the finished
dissertation as a mine but I think that
it's gonna be a very important work and
I definitely want to see it get
published and get a you know wide
audience and traction so again if you
haven't checked out Sean Miller's ideas
Google that his blog will come up a lot
of really interesting material in there
his Instagram is coffee and research all
one word any other plugs that we should
we should make I mean I have a Twitter
account I don't use it that much
something to do but it's at Sean D
Miller okay well thank you very much for
the thank you the chance to talk about
this I think that the viewers are going
to be very interested in these topics I
hope so
you